One of the potential side effects of my chemo therapy treatment is brittle bones, seems to be true in my case.
I've had two very minor falls with the last bead about four months ago. I broke four ribs each time.
Although I am much better, they still haven't really healed as evidenced by my CT scans.
Would you have recommendations for supplements or diet that might be helpful for healing or strengthening of bones?
Also my wife is similar supplemental dietary question pertaining to age related osteoporosis.
So the treatment for osteoporosis or to help build bones that are damaged via lytic metastasis
is not simply just to take calcium.
So used to be thought years ago that everybody should be on 1500 milligrams of calcium.
That's what was promoted back in the late 80s and 90s.
It was just, it was incorrect information.
So what it led to is people haven't, you know, having, having hardening to the arteries, having arterial sclerosis issues
and not actually increasing the density of bones.
So how do you increase the density of the bone?
Well, do we need calcium? Well, yeah, you do need minerals.
But nobody should be taking more than a few hundred milligrams of calcium.
Even of the good source of calcium, you know, who was worse back in the 80s and 90s people were taking a poor source of calcium,
which was, which made, which complicated the problem even be worse.
It's not so much the amount of calcium you're taking because you could, you really shouldn't take more than a couple hundred milligrams of calcium per day,
even if you have horrible osteoporosis or loss of calcium, loss of bone density through the lytic metastasis.
What you need is MK7. So you need vitamin K in the form of MK4, I mean.
So most of the vitamin K that's out there is going to be in the form of MK7.
That's, that's not the form that you need to get calcium in the bone.
It's MK4 and you need a very high dose of MK4 in order to get calcium in the bone.
I interviewed a gentleman about this. I have a blog post about this.
The bottom line is there's only literally one supplement that I recommend for osteoporosis, osteopaedia, or loss of bone density due to metastasis.
And that is a product called osteo-K-O-S-T-E-O-K.
We have it on our store. I interviewed the gentleman who basically developed this in one of the blogs, so you could search for that as well.
But that's what you would take. So depending upon the amount of bone loss and bone regeneration that you need to take places,
the dose that you take, you take up to, I think, two to four these a day. The person just has mild osteoporosis.
I suggest literally just one of these a day if you have a greater amount than you increase that for a period of time and it's not taken forever.
So osteo-K is the product for osteopaedia, osteoporosis, or bone loss due to metastasis.